let me jump to this story here about
another crime that took place in New
York City homeless men charged with hate
crimes for defecating on Pride flags at
Manhattan Eatery
they're trying to give him the maximum
sentence blasphemy laws yep
they said that uh him taking a dump on a
pride flag and wiping his butt with it
was a hate crime and intolerance you
know I think I think he's just some
homeless guy was looking for a place to
take a dump that's it and they're like
why didn't use napkins and I'm like I
don't know that he was thinking at all
why did the guy in the subway platform
push the woman onto the into the front
of the train why did he murder her I
mean these people aren't well when it
comes to the guy in the train who is
desperate and hungry what did AOC say it
should not be a death sentence for this
man who is just hungry and unwell into
the city's fault
is this man not hungry and unwell when
he pooped on a pride flag exactly so so
I mentioned this the other day whenever
it comes to an act of Senseless violence
a million and one different excuses are
made and we have to go into a deep
socioeconomic analysis of what could
have led that person who we think is a
criminal but is truly a victim to feel
that they needed to commit that
disordered act and then of course when
you speak out against the party you're
not afforded that same luxury they don't
make a million or one excuses they don't
play mental gymnastics to make what you
did seem okay within their framework
because we just never funded that inner
city library that would have educated
you and made you a more enlightened
functioning member of society and in
part it's because
when you go out against the narrative
because they're single-minded that means
you are responsible for all of the
world's ills the reason violent crime
happens is because we're not allocating
our resources properly and under the
religion of Marxism simply moving
material things around in the material
world solves all of the problems let's
put the wealth here instead of there and
then there won't be any more crime we'll
stop it all from happening and because
you're not on board with that you're
responsible for every violent act so by
simply criticizing the Party by doing
what he did in disgracing or desecrating
an lgbtq flag
she is contributing to Serious violence
this is actually how their minds work
because he's taking away from The
credibility of their philosophy which
will fix everything if we just let it
take a look at this story from Daily
Mail
Cleaver wielding convict terrorizes Bart
trained passengers trapped in underwater
tunnel by pacing up and down train
threatening them then slashing man in
the back if only we built that inner
city library if you try in any way to
stop this man you will go to prison
you must allow him to chop you into
pieces before you try to defend yourself
every society every society has
something they hold sacred there's no
escaping this we all do it every society
does this and we pretend like we're
Beyond it we pretend like we'd be
Advanced behind this Behavior no you
haven't you will have something sacred
and for us it is this diversity equity
and inclusion it is the pride flag it is
the racial hierarchy for us these are
the things but but increasingly it is at
the cult I think it is becoming the
values of the nation I think it is
becoming the values of almost every
institution from the military to the
media and look obviously I'm against
this stuff but I think it's hard to
pretend like this isn't not now come to
dominate the vast majority I know I I
think I think you're wrong I think
Budweiser proves the people of this
country do not hold these things sacred
that's that's the difference though
you're you're you're correct that it's
not it's not a Grassroots popular thing
it's totally astroturfed and you're
right it's coming from the institutions
because the people that are going to
school and graduating as they see
graduating and going on to be CEOs and
stuff they're bringing this into the
into the boardroom with them there was a
long time where people thought kids were
going to go to school they were going to
do this stuff in sociology and in the
humanities and then they would get out
into the real world and the real world
would fix them well guess what they're
bringing it into the boardroom and
making it they're putting it into the HR
departments and making it the standard
culture in broader society and culture
is Downstream from power it does not
matter what the average person thinks it
doesn't matter what the masses think it
matters who the influential people The
Taste makers the institutions the power
Brokers it matters what they think
because they then inform what people
think how popular was Trans in kids five
years ago oh not at all yeah just five
years ago it didn't exist right and now
it's everywhere it's the dominant
dominant thing it's the center of the
cultural battle why is that because 70
of America suddenly decided they really
cared about mutilating children no it's
because they were told what to care
about and so but I think it was actually
because people on the Right started
pushing back against it and then the
left started widely promoting it
in in popular media well
it's complicated right because this is
what the left none of this stuff Force
something onto the general culture just
as you've mentioned very powerful people
will start pushing this stuff they'll
put it on television they'll promote it
on social media they'll have the
algorithm Orient people towards this
kind of content that normalizes this
truly abhorrent disgusting perverted
behavior in the abuse of children and
then when normal healthy people who
aren't just gonna go along with what the
culture tells them they should believe
say that's sick because that is the
mutilation of children their response is
why do you care so much why do you care
so much people are always going to be
trans people have been trans you know
etc etc but your average have an answer
what when someone says why do you care
oh I do have an answer I do have an
answer to that question I'm saying for
the average person listen oh yeah yeah
know your answer absolutely absolutely
and you should be able to have an answer
to that question but my point is that
they play this game where they make
something an issue and then they ask why
you're paying attention to it
will they create the problem because
they believe they have the solution and
because the dialectic gets Advanced that
way right because now you need to
moderate it okay you didn't even have a
position on this before but now you need
a more moderate position so you can find
some kind of consensus inside a
dialectic that was created for you
artificially yeah so this wasn't even
you didn't need to have this debate and
now it's essentially you for not only to
have this debate but to move your
position in that debate closer to
whatever the progressive position is and
that is a key thing that people have to
understand exactly and that's why
conservatives end up letting go of
cultural ground because what happens is
first people understand that like
marriage between a man and woman for the
purposes of procreation well now
contraceptive starts to become
normalized and conservatives start to
fight that and then people start talking
about gay marriage and okay now fighting
contraceptive seems outdated we're going
to try to fight gay marriage now people
have decided that two men can be married
even though that's literally impossible
given the definition of the term but now
they're saying that we can trans
children a man can become a woman you go
over there and you try to fight that now
again they're pushing it on to kids so
conservatives jump from fight to fight
to fight to fight because the left keeps
setting
I got a question for you guys if uh uh
if an antifa guy was on a subway and it
happened to him that some guy like
started beating the crap out of him and
then he got into a fight now he's
getting arrested how would you feel wait
can you repeat that like the antifa guys
herself is on a train
and some guys threatening people and the
guy in the antifa shirt grabs the guy
and subdues him and gets arrested for it
how do you feel
I feel about the same way
so you would donate to the antifa guy's
defense I'm not donating to his
son no no I wouldn't but people
listening I'd love to hear your thoughts
would you if there was a guy wearing a
Bernie Sanders 2024 or Joe Biden Biden
Harris 2024 shirt and
and he grabbed this guy and and you know
because the guy was on the train
threatening people would you would you
donate to them
that's a good question I mean if he was
an antifa I wouldn't need to donate to
him because no one would try to press
charges I'm saying if they did my point
is you get these people who live in
these cities and there's an 85 chance
this guy is a Democrat voter and
everyone's like quick quick give him
give him money and I'm like I mean maybe
is is he a guy who actually believes in
American values who is fighting for
those values or is it the overwhelming
likelihood 85 percent that somebody who
lives in these cities especially after
we've seen the mass Exodus from
moderates and conservatives the
likelihood is even greater this is some
Biden voter who is getting what he voted
for no I mean I hear you I'm 100 behind
the right having legal defense funds and
standing up for people I think that's a
level of infrastructure that absolutely
has to happen but you have to use that
wisely you can't just throw it for
people who are in you know like I said
putting yourself in that situation
likely political enemies you should be
putting it towards people who you know
are going to be using it properly so I'm
generally in favor of these
organizations existing people making
these kind of donations but you do have
to be thinking about what you're
actually applying that to people can
give whatever they want I'm I I hope
this guy does not go to prison I hope he
wins I'm glad people are supporting him
I'm just saying at what point are we
going to be like look I'll put it this
way I left New York a long time ago
because a black supremacist murdered
some cops and I said I am not going to
live in a place that is like this I am
not going to have my tax dollars go to a
city one of the it's the one of the only
stages of income tax and one of the
highest income taxes for a resident in
the in the country in the world and then
I'm in the Jersey side someone plants
bombs and I'm like okay better not be in
this place but we end up in a place
where where we're at in the tri-state
the the tri-state area and the Eastern
panhandle of West Virginia is moderately
purple for for the area you've got
Maryland which of course is a is a major
Battleground and and very left very
Democrat and then the Eastern panhandles
is maybe surprising people of West
Virginia the schools are very very
welcome they're trying to indoctrinate
kids so now I feel pretty good about
where I'm at I feel safe I have
constitutional carry but we're in a
local jurisdiction where there's a
actually some serious concerns with the
school board and recently the GOP was
talking about despite the fact that
they've won the school board they still
have this woke stuff that they're trying
to push out because this is a key
Battleground now my concern is are we
giving money to Democrats who voted for
this because we're not paying attention
and we assume because this guy did a
good thing that he is a good guy I mean
if this if it turns out this guy doesn't
really live there I just moved there and
he's a big Trump supporter and he's been
fighting against this stuff and he's
been posting about it I'll be like okay
this is a guy needs our help Kyle
Rittenhouse is in a suburban area he was
in he was in a split area uh politically
and he was there as an innocent kid
trying to help clean up his neighborhood
actively fighting for his neighborhood
and trying to help even the protesters
and that was years ago and we're like
okay now it's several years on and we're
immediately knee-jerk jumping to the
defense of a guy we don't know
who could turn out to be the biggest Joe
Biden supporter who voted for all of
this and that's my concern giving money
to the people who are making the problem
happen if you live in New York
especially after the Summer of Love
riots especially after Chauvin Ahmed
Arbury Kim Potter Etc
especially after even the the 25 people
being shot in front of trains the
likelihood is not that this person is
someone who believes in our values and
is going to be fighting for them the
likelihood is it's just some default
liberal guy who's supporting Joe Biden
so I'll I'll wait and I'll see you know
we'll see how this plays out but that's
my biggest concern are we as people who
want to push back who are buying
Jeremy's chocolate who are who are
buying Jeremy's razors then going to
donate to Democrats when they get
themselves in trouble are we going to be
the people who are contributing to the
bail funds of of antifolic extremists
when Kamala Harris and Joe Biden's staff
raised money for the far left Riders we
were we were like this is abhorrent how
this is ridiculous how dare you do this
so my question now is when you get
people who live in these cities
the overwhelming likelihood that they
support these things so so what is what
is that issue right now is it that we
assume he must not support these things
because he tried to subdue a crazy
person
no I don't I don't necessarily believe
that the woman who got punched in the
face clearly didn't want to get punched
in the face but you know she votes
Democrat this this pink-haired hippie
lady who lives in New York City it's a
90 chance she did and you go and talk to
these people and you ask them like are
you going to vote Democrat they'll say
yes in fact what about the rise and
crime will say I don't care or that
woman in San Francisco said I will never
call the police and then she gets
murdered are we gonna donate to people
like that I don't know man that's tough
there's I don't find any significant
flaw with what you're saying like I
personally I don't see a whole lot of
reason to donate to people that to that
live in cities like you say it's like
they're there they stay there that's
what they're asking for that's what they
want most people again aren't aware of
the aren't even aware of their situation
so I I don't see a big reason to to
argue with you about it I mean look
we'll see people are saying that he's
from Long Island he's a Marine he's
probably not a Democrat and it's like
okay you know like let's let's see what
he has to say when he put a statement he
his lawyer could have put out a
statement that said something like New
York has seen violent crime escalating
rapidly for several years and the people
of the city are tired of it when this
man violently threatened the passengers
of this train Daniel um our client
Daniel Penny along with two others found
it reasonable to try and subdue him to
protect the lives of others did they do
that no they said it's so sad and
unfortunate that people are suffering in
this city
they they gave a woke they were awoke
statement that many conservatives
started complaining about on Twitter but
now they're willing to throw money at
these people who are just giving this
like default tepid response
I just think I don't know man
don't don't look at me I don't have all
the answers y'all can do what you want
you know yeah I'm surprised he hasn't
come out and said anything at all if we
were to come out and he did well did he
justify his position no yeah
the statement they issued on his behalf
was just lamenting the poor homeless of
New York City I will say the point of
that statement though is to try to
Defuse The the protest as opposed to so
I mean you may it may not be well that's
what he's trying to do and to be honest
with you if you're in that situation I
get a dude who's not really like
engulfed in the culture War I can get
why he'd be like yo what do I what am I
supposed to do to calm people down and
get myself out of that there there is
the again people don't know what they
you know people don't know the laws that
they live under most of the time they
don't realize what laws get passed uh
and they don't pay a whole lot of
attention to politics they should
absolutely I'm not saying that you know
their ignorance is is uh is fine or
whatever but at the same time it's like
he's probably got no idea what he's
gotten himself into and he's like what
do I do to make this go away and so so
often there's just no connection with
these people I live down in Florida and
we get all these people down from New
York come down they move they can't
believe what's happened in New York they
don't want to live there anymore they're
finally out of there but what's the
first thing they do when they come down
to Florida oh I can't believe what
DeSantis is doing I can't believe all
these things that you're living here I
can't believe your politics are like
this it's like there's no connection
they don't they they genuinely do not
understand how one thing leads to the
next they just come down and think oh
well there's some kind of magical reason
that this place is safer there was that
Viral thread where a guy from San
Francisco was like we moved to Florida
because the crime was getting too bad
and then someone said just you know
don't don't vote Democrat and then
someone leftist was like you're going to
support DeSantis and his response was
immediately to be like no no I'm left
wing and I'm going to vote Democrat oh
my gosh well this is part of the
complexity here right so you were
mentioning earlier that we want people
to leave these cities if they're you
know and at all decent person but then
when people leave and they end up voting
for the same policies it makes
everything worse in the states they go
to and I know ideal really you would
have conservatives leaving New York and
go into a place like Florida but I'm
sorry a New York conservative is not the
same as a Florida I do think that the
the viewership of of timcast is probably
the kind of people that we're talking to
it matters I I don't expect that people
that would be you know tuning in to
timcast and say you know what Tim's
right I'm going to move would be the
kind of people that would be like oh now
I'm completely gonna vote I was in I was
in Chicago I had a couple hundred bucks
and I just left I and I went to I went
to California and I was just like I'm
I'm leaving this place crime corruption
police were were uh like all the stories
a cop choke slams a woman because a
meter maid the the police are operating
black sites and I'm like I definitely
don't want to be here and so I'm gonna
get out and Grant that I was 23 is easy
for a 23 year old but there was a lot of
risk I was planning on being homeless
and I got I got lucky in finding a place
and meeting some people I got to sleep
on a couch periodically and sleep on the
floor
I'm just saying like at this point we've
already seen most people flee to Florida
and now Rhonda Santos is winning by a
million votes people fled to Texas
that's where the biggest uh uh influx of
new American of of migrants was American
internal where they call it net
migration people fled California they
fled New York
I don't know why we care so much about
these places New York and California you
know what I mean
like the the corruption is off the
charts like that you've got in San
Francisco Cleaver wielding convict
terrorizing the train aoc's not saying
anything about this did she come out and
say like we really got to stop these
people terrorizing said is it like no I
don't know at a certain point I'm like
bro you reap what you sow you live there
you live there
well what AOC has said is we need a
National Railway system and I can't wait
to see how safe and wonderful that is
it'll be really good news when all those
people from New York can get right to
Florida in just a moment I just really
appreciate that that'll be awesome so I
guess one of the one of the nice things
about the United States one of the
things that makes it work is that we can
be far away from you guys they keep
saying it's kind of nice they keep
saying we need a nationwide rail service
and I keep saying why because they want
to go out of planes exactly well they
want to get rid of planes they want to
get rid of automobiles they want you to
have zero privacy or autonomy you gotta
be on the mass transit so you have to be
on the the large uh Mass the high-speed
Railway system with the rambling
homeless person who's swinging a machete
at people
maybe that's it for real though no it is
a lot of a lot of Subway crime has been
popping up in all of these cities and
they want to take away your ability to
have a car they want to put you in this
yeah I want to take away your ability to
defend yourself yeah the whole point of
Prosecuting I think they might just want
you to die you know what I mean I mean
you are the carbon that they want to
eliminate I mean if you're going to have
a total state if you're gonna have a
totalitarian state you got to get rid of
individuality and communities you got to
get rid of the autonomy that little
Regional communities provide the ability
people to get away you have to make
everybody dependent on the system so
yeah I think that's absolutely you have
to convince people that the Senate is is
uh undemocratic and good I'm glad more
on democracy please
you know exactly why they want to get
rid of it oh I know the Senate it's not
like it's going to be some kind of
positive thing if they were to get rid
of the Senate
um but you know that the point of
getting rid of the Senate is because
they want to you know they don't want to
have states that are individuated and
have have autonomy and stuff that to the
progressives is bad so yeah I wonder if
if a lot you know these people are
malthusian they think there's too many
people and they want to get rid of them
I wonder if a lot of these policies
aren't necessarily about individually
killing any person it's about creating a
net pressure which results in the long
term with a declining population
I mean they don't have to do that that's
already happening that social
engineering's already getting them there
if they did it right then that's the
point that's what I'm saying like are
these policies put in place for the
reason of creating a pressure which
results in a lower population the thing
is I don't even know I don't think it's
that well thought out I just think that
Society is a thing that people have to
constantly work to upkeep and progress
so it's not something that someone just
built for us and then left here and we
can allow to sit it has to constantly be
up kept by people living virtuous lives
and when you don't want to live a
virtuous life you just rationalize that
and when you try to rationalize that in
a wide scale political sense you just
call it leftism so all these policies
are are people attempting to rationalize
the abdication of their responsibility
to uphold our society and culture well I
can I can put another way for you
Sheamus there was this uh TV show
where they were tracking fat women and
it was like why why are they fat or
whatever and This Woman's like I have a
glandular problem and then what they did
was they filmed her throughout the day
and they were like at the end they said
how much how many calories do you think
you ate and she was like probably 1200
for I had a light breakfast with just
some eggs for lunch I had a salad and
for dinner I had you know small steak
and they were like you had
4763 calories like what and then they
showed the video of her grabbing cookies
and candies and snack cakes and stuff
like that all throughout the day and
that that to me is it the
rationalization of it's just one cupcake
yes it's only to 150 calories to have a
one cup it doesn't matter and then you
do it a hundred times well yeah exactly
and that and that's how Vice works right
when a person builds virtually they're
not going I only won you don't have to
rationalize it in that way thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time